Let's take a deeper look into
when an iterable actually is.
Here I've got my array, and I'm
looping over it, and I'm console
logging the cut. No big deal.
But what if I want to get the
index of the actual cut as well
to say Chuck is first, Brisket
is second, etc., etc.? There's
no real good way to do that
right here unless I were to say
cuts to indexOf and find it
every single time. What we
don't know about yet is that
there are these things called
generators - and we're going to
go into a whole bunch of that in
the video - but if you go into
your console here and do this
with me, say cuts.entries, what
that is going to give us is
actually an array iterator. If
you open it up you'd expect to
see all the data, but there's
nothing in there. All you know
that there's a Next function
that we can call on it. So if
we actually store that array
cuts.entries in a variable, so
const, say meat=cuts.entries.
Now what do we have? Meat. Is
that all of the meat? No, it's
the iterator and we can iterate
through each of those ones
manually. This loop was doing it
for us, but if we ever wanted to
do it manually - and we'll look
at more examples when we hit
generators - you call it meat.
next, and meat.next, and then
meat.next. Let's see what we
got there, a couple of more
times, there we go. So what do
we get here? Well, the first
time we called it we got done:
false, and that means that the
loop hasn't finished -- more in
the generator video. Then the
value is in array where the
first thing is going to be the
index, and the second thing is
going to be the actual value.
The second one, one is brisket,
third one, fourth one, you
probably get the point. It tells
us what the index does is and
what the short rib is. Why would
this be useful to us in this
video where we're learning about
four of? Because what you can do
is if we iterate over not just
the plain array but we iterate
over the array iterator which is .
entries, watch what we'll get
now. OK, so now we get cut is
not chuck brisket, cut is an
array every single time that we
go through it. Now you might be
saying, "That's annoying because
now I have to say cut zero and
cut one to get the index and the
value." But hopefully you're
screaming at me right now and
you're going to say, "Well, Wes
I can use destructuring there,
right?" Because what we can do
is we can say for const, index,
and cut, because each of this is
going to return an array, we can
just immediately destructure
that into their own variables,
so const I and cut. Now, if we
just console.log I. Let's put
this in a tablet string. Cut is
the I item. Now we should have a
variable.cut and a variable
called I, there we go, chuck is
the zero item, brisket is the
first item, second, and third
etc., etc.. If you wanted to
offset that you would just add
one to it in first, second and
third and fourth. Good. What
are we doing here? We're using
cuts.entries to bring us an
iterator. For...of, this is kind
of the nice thing about for...of,
is it can pretty much handle
anything that you throw at it.
You don't have to think, "What
kind of data is this? Which of
mine like four or different
loops that I have available to
me should I use?" In almost all
cases, except for objects, you
can just use your for...of, and
just throw anything at it, and
the for...of loop is going to
just figure out how to handle
that data for you. So here I've
destructured the data as we
actually go on in, and we're off
and running with that. Let's
look at another example where
for...of is useful. That is when
you're trying to iterate over
the arguments objects. I'm just
going to take this out for a
second. Let's say we have a
function called add up numbers.
And that function is going to be
called like this, add up numbers.
You have no idea how many
numbers are going to get passed.
Maybe some of this is going to
pass a whole bunch of them. When
you're declaring the function,
you can't really like put a
whole bunch of placeholders,
like num1, num2, num3, just in
case they past that many,
because you have absolutely no
idea how many arguments are
going to pass. So instead of
putting anything in there, what
we can do inside of this
function is to just console.log
this variable called arguments.
Now that is a special word and
it's going to be in array-ish
type where it will give us all
of the actual arguments. So
let's take a look here. Cool.
That arguments is now what looks
to be an array, it's not exactly
an array of everything that got
passed in. Why I'm so bent up on
saying it's array-ish is because
if you open it up, you'll see a
couple of things right here.
First of all the prototype is
not an array. What happens, let
me just console.log a regular
array just to show you. One, two,
three. This is a regular array.
Open that sucker up. The
prototype of that thing was the
array, and if you open that up
you'll see here's all the crazy
array methods that we're used to
like every entries, and cat, and
map, and push, and pop, and
reduce, and everything we could
possibly want, right? Because
that has built up a proper array.
Now, arguments is simply just a
list with only one thing on it:
length. However, you can iterate
over it with the for...of loop
because it has a symbol iterator.
Normally, in a case like this, I
would probably just convert
arguments to a real array and
use a reduce on it and add them
all up. But for whatever reason,
if you're ever in the use-case
where you cannot convert your
arguments to an object maybe for
some performance reasons, or
whatever you have, then you can
go ahead and loop over arguments
without first converting to an
array. There's no need to
convert it to an array if you
just need to loop over them.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to say let total=zero,
start with zero and then I'm
going to loop over each of them.
So I'm going to say for num in
arguments total + = num then we
should be able to return the
total here. That should add them
all up, let's see. I'm going to
console.log total as well just
so we can see it. I've got a
bit of an error here. What is my
mistake here, can you spot it?
Why is it saying 00123456?
Because I said for...in, it's
for...of, not for...in. For...in
would give us the index. For...
of will give us the actual
argument. Refresh. There we go,
267, because I created a
variable and it looped through
it and it updated every single
one of them. Now, if I ever want
to call add up numbers, what's
10 + 10? 20. What if I want to
do a whole bunch, more of them?
Not a problem, it's going to
give me 256, appropriate. That
is one example of what you could
loop over it. You do not need to
convert to a true array, you can
just use the for...of to iterate
over it. What else can we use to
the for...of to iterate over?
That's for a string, so maybe
you have a name like Wes Bos.
I'm going to say for const
character of name, console.log,
the character, and that will
give us the s-base B-O-S. Notice
how I put a const there? I think
I forgot. Yeah. You make sure
you put a const, a let, or a var
in front of this, otherwise
you're going to be overwriting
the actual variable every single
time instead of creating a let
or a const that is scoped to
that actual block. Finally, you
can also loop over DAM
collections without having to
convert to a true array. Now,
DOM collections, or nodeless or
HTML collections, whatever
you're going to call them, they
are being changed so that you
will have all of your .for each,
and .map, and all of those array
methods that you're used to.
However, in most browsers they
are not a true array, so we
could use the for...of, no
problem there. Maybe we'll give
ourselves a couple of paragraph
tags in the body up here. Let's
just say a paragraph that says
something like IIOP$, let's give
ourselves 10 of them. Cool so
I've got a whole bunch of
paragraphs on the page here,
let's see them all right here.
Then I want to select them, say
const piece = document.
querySelector all paragraph.
Then I'm just going to console.
log the paragraphs. So this,
open it up. See, it's not a true
array it is a nodeless, but if
you open that up you will see
that we have dot for each as
well as a couple other of the
array methods that we're used to.
If you want to loop over it with
a for...of loop, or const
paragraph of piece, then
we can console.log the paragraph,
you see that we get each
individual one here, and that's
useful if you want to do
something like paragraph at
event listener on click,
function, console.log, .text
content. Anytime someone clicks
on a paragraph go ahead and
console.log whatever is inside
of it. Do three if you want, do
two if you want. Good. Didn't
need to convert it to an array.
Again, you totally can. I'm not
sure of a huge performance
difference between the two. You
can do your own testing on that.
But it's helpful to know that
you can use this for...of with
things that aren't arrays, as
long as they're an iterable. And
what is an iterable, a DOM
collection, argument, a string,
an array, a map, or a set.